[Music]
hey what's up mkbhd here this is a key
fob and the key fob unlocks this which
is the most impressive electric truck i
have ever seen this is the rivien r1t so
it's literally brand new it's just
hitting the streets and for the next 24
hours i'm gonna drive it i'm gonna daily
it i'm gonna live with it spend some
time with it and then i'm gonna try to
answer all the questions people have had
about it that i possibly can and there
are a lot of questions because this is a
very hyped up vehicle this is maybe the
most promising of any of the evs coming
out of the startups you know we have all
the old manufacturers of course making
lots of promises to electrify their
lineups but there's also a lot of really
interesting stuff from the teslas and
lucids and rimacs of the world
this i think is the most interesting of
all of them right now thanks in part by
their background with amazon and ford so
this is rivien's first consumer vehicle
it's a pickup truck it's called the r1t
so i've got it here in this sort of
pacific blue color and the basic specs
are this it's quad motors one on each 21
inch all-terrain wheel 314 miles of
range
0-60 in three seconds flat which is
hilariously quick for a pickup truck and
then this is the launch edition with the
adventure package which includes you
know a lot of the most premium interior
finishes it has the off-road upgrade and
pretty much all the options so it starts
at just over seventy thousand dollars
and it can quickly jump up into mid 80s
or 90 plus from there so definitely
premium but it's packing a lot of stuff
that makes it feel worth the price
so number one what's good with this
design right so rivien is a new company
they don't really have a heritage or a
design dna where they have to keep
certain shapes in mind when designing
their vehicle so
really they could have made whatever
they wanted and at the end of the day
they chose this shape for a short bed
electric pickup truck personally
i do actually like a lot of the design
here it's not completely crazy out of
this world like a cyber truck but it's
also not flying way under the radar like
the f-150 lightning it's kind of
somewhere in between it has a lot of
modern shapes and modern touches and
really the biggest feature that of
course stands out looking at it is the
bar tail light across the back which i
love
and the face
the bar plus headlights across the front
which
definitely takes some getting used to
but again i think it's pretty nice the
headlights on each side are the most
powerful and that's where the high beams
are and everything but the entire bar
light is functional and you definitely
find that out pretty quick driving it at
night like i did so that's cool and i
also do like this blue color which is
one of a bunch of colors that they have
that i think are really adventurey and i
gotta say this truck turns more heads
than anything else i have ever driven i
think a lot of it is the face but like
more than any other electric car more
than any mclaren more than any tesla all
day people are coming up to it asking
about it pointing at it it definitely
makes a statement right now and someone
on twitter told me it looks kind of like
this truck is 50 years old and from the
future at the same time i feel like that
actually hits the nail on the head okay
number two how's the interior
so it's really good and also doesn't
really look like anything else but if i
had to describe it it's kind of like if
someone combined the layout from a tesla
with the wood and leather and metal type
finishes from a volvo or something and
then stuffed a bunch of extra features
in it so this is the black mountain
interior color so pretty much everything
inside is matte black and it just gives
me the impression that there's a lot of
thought that went into a lot of the
little things so like the back of the
seats each one of them has a coat hook
and a usb type-c port there's a wireless
charger between the front seats there's
also a bunch of hidden features in this
interior too which i'll get to in a
second don't worry space-wise though it
is still it's a compact pickup truck for
sure much smaller than say a full-size
f-150 the panoramic glass roof
definitely helps it feel more spacious
when you're sitting inside and there's
plenty of legroom in the second row
which is awesome but from left to right
i probably wouldn't put three people in
this middle seat i think there's a video
somewhere with three people on the back
of the rivian and you know it's fine
they all fit but probably wouldn't want
to do that for a multi-hour road trip
all right so number three if it's a
small truck
how's the storage
so here's the thing it's small for truck
but since it's an electric truck there's
no engine under the hood no transmission
running through the middle and it
absolutely maximizes the space inside in
every way so it's a small bed four and a
half feet with the tailgate up plenty
for me personally but smaller than some
other trucks out there there's also
supposed to be a bed cover that wasn't
working on this early model i'm driving
but that will give you about 29 cubic
feet which can be extended a bit to a
seven foot length when you open the
tailgate since it sort of slides this
extra piece down between the bed and the
gate for larger items then there's also
storage underneath the bed for an
optional full-size spare but that space
also has a drain plug in case you wanted
to use it as a cooler or something
then in the front there is a fully
powered lift gate revealing a massive
front trunk and again this this is so
nice for a pickup truck there's more
than enough room to fit several bags you
can go grocery shopping with just the
front trunk and the fact that it powers
up and down like a regular trunk and
even has this little button underneath
the front headlights to open and close
it to me it's so convenient that i kind
of feel like i would use this more than
the back like for covered locked storage
this is great this is great for a pickup
truck then inside the truck there is a
lot of storage too there's actually no
normal spot for a glove box which is
funny it's just a leather paneling here
but there's a huge amount of storage in
this super deep center console where you
can clip papers and stuff that would
normally go in a glove box there's
storage in the doors there's storage
inside a little pocket in the front of
the front seats which is kind of random
but cool and then there are in fact
pop-out cup holders in the middle
between the front seats there's even the
back seat of course for casual storage
but also even more hidden storage
underneath the back seats
and then maybe the most iconic extra
space on this entire truck
the gear tunnel so that is this column
of space with a cover on both sides
that's right between the rear wheel and
the back seats it's actually super cool
i'm not sure what you'd specifically use
this space for when it's empty you know
you could fit technically a whole set of
golf clubs in here or a couple backpacks
or something you know it can definitely
fit some larger duffel bags it can fit a
human body you know we have to try a lot
of you guys were asking on twitter but
it's not just the space here that's
useful there are power outlets inside of
this tunnel on either side and the doors
that open on either side are actually
strong enough that they can support up
to 300 pounds so you can sit on it you
can even use it as a step to climb over
and into the bed of the truck
and there's storage inside those doors
for even more stuff and in case whatever
you're hauling here is precious you can
actually access the gear tunnel from
inside the truck from between the back
seats you pull that armrest down and you
can reach inside behind this cover into
the middle of the gear tunnel to grab
whatever stuff you have in here i've
never seen anything like this in any
other truck
and yeah i love it
so your grand total just for the spec
sheet 68 cubic feet of storage in this
compact pickup truck that's massive
okay number four how does it drive well
i know most people aren't buying pickup
trucks just for the way they drive but
if you do care about that this is an
incredibly impressive truck to drive now
like you saw this one's running on
21-inch all-terrain wheels so it's not
even set up to drive like a sports car
clearly but any time you combine quad
motors
totaling 800 plus horsepower
with a world-class air suspension it
kind of doesn't matter how much the
thing weighs this truck absolutely hauls
0-60 in three seconds flat which is
amazing it does taper off after that but
that is a crazy fast time for a truck
and it feels fast there's a couple of
different driving modes to talk about
most of the time you can just leave it
in all-purpose mode and it can handle
pretty much any daily driving the air
suspension has a massive range of
adjustment for how much clearance how
much ride height you need and there's a
couple options you can have a stiff or
soft ride and you can turn brake regen
to low or high which i've kept it on
high as much as possible while driving
because it is actually calibrated for
one pedal driving which is awesome
and stability on or off
so yeah on the road it's crazy i know i
said the number but just to say it again
zero to sixty and three seconds flat
that'll be in sport mode where you can
also have the firm ride and the
suspension really does turn extra firm
and minimize roll obviously only having
it for a day i couldn't
take it to a track or anything but
it's a it's a pickup truck i'll just say
i've never had more fun driving a truck
ever so great for highway driving has a
pretty tight turning radius too for a
truck which is partially due to the
torque vectoring you get from having one
motor at each wheel
now there's also a conserve mode which
is good for saving battery and
maximizing your range if you're doing
some sort of road trip stuff and it
really does hunker down the suspension
in the sport and conserve modes for the
best aerodynamic efficiency and the firm
ride but i'm sure that most people are
most interested in the off-road stuff
which actually has several versions has
automatic rock crawl
rally
and drift mode casual now i didn't
really get to really off-road in the
couple of hours that i'm out here near
the studio in new jersey but i did take
it off on a dirt path that i would never
take my car and it's a truck it handled
it with ease with these tires as you'd
expect and it was a pretty great demo
actually of how the suspension
can really go from very firm to very
soft and adaptive and just absorb all
the rocks and the terrain so this truck
is capable of
way more off-roading than i was able to
throw at it the bottom is plated in
metal and there are even more aggressive
off-roading tire packages there's a
great video from zach on the j-rig
everything channel where he gets to put
it through some rock crawling and the
thing absolutely eats whatever you throw
at it and it does it in silence too
that's the thing i mean we all already
knew evs were quiet but there's
something about driving around through
crazy mud or rocks in nature and not
drowning out everything with the sound
of the engine but just hearing the tires
basically so off-roading was eerily
quiet in a good way
all right so number five what makes the
rivien different from other evs or other
trucks well the form factor is already
pretty unique as a small pickup truck
but they're also really leaning into
this like adventure thing you're
supposed to think of this more as an
adventure vehicle than a normal truck
and that kind of sounds cheesy at first
but hey they're throwing everything but
the kitchen sink at it to live up to
that
actually they're literally even throwing
a kitchen sink at this thing so look all
right in the driver's side door there's
a flashlight that clicks away here
hidden away and it's powered by one of
the car's batteries matter of fact it
actually has one of those exact cells
inside and it just sits here wireless
charging in case you ever need it and
it's a legit super bright flashlight
apparently the reason they did this is
because there are 7776
of these batteries in the bottom of the
truck and rj the founder just really
wanted a nice number so the flashlight
had to happen so the story goes either
way that's a nice little addition then
not only are there two full outlets in
the trunk but there's also an air
compressor that can go up to 150 psi and
it comes with a 20 foot hose that can
reach all four tires so you can
literally inflate your tires with a
built-in compressor on the truck or do
whatever else you want with the air
compressor it's just there anytime you
need it
and if you check underneath the center
armrest there's a whole bluetooth
speaker separate from the car sound
system that just lives under there and
wireless charges all the time too it's
got a huge battery it's got lights it's
got a usbc port to charge your phone it
can easily be the centerpiece of a
camping trip or whatever sort of
adventure is happening around this car
that's pretty sick i love that and then
the gear tunnel of course
is ripe for possibilities so
it already has a full-size outlet inside
and tons of space but then there's a 5
000 option on their site for a camp
kitchen that expands to reveal a 1400
watt stove top a 4 gallon water tank a
countertop and a 30 piece cutlery set
just sitting in the back of your truck
it's just it's very impressive that the
whole thing just slots back into the
tunnel when you're done using it and
there's more that can fit back here and
i'm sure there will be more third-party
stuff to slot into the gear tunnel in
the future it's super dope the cherry on
top instead of a horn this adventure
vehicle makes a locking sound inspired
by nature
all right so number six what's the
charging situation right it's electric
like i said 314 miles of range which is
pretty decent so it's it's public
chargers and home chargers only for now
which it will happily route you to on
the map which is good the spec sheet
says it supports 200 kilowatts fast
charging speeds i stopped at an
electrify america station near the
studio with around 35 battery left and
while the station says it supported 150
kilowatts the car itself never got over
100 and was quoting me about an hour to
charge the remaining two-thirds of the
battery so this is part of the big early
question with a lot of these evs as of
right now they can't use the tesla
supercharging network and this is
supposed to be
a vehicle you really want to adventure
with so you really don't want to be
thinking about how much range you have
left you kind of just want to go drive
off into the woods and not think about
it so ideally this rivian adventure
network that they're promising will
start to get built up soon now if you're
a day one customer getting a truck today
that doesn't exist yet but they're
planning on building a bunch of fast
chargers at the most convenient
locations for adventures and that'll
kind of act like the tesla supercharger
network for rivian charges fast you can
monitor it through the app etc
we'll see though it's getting built i'll
believe it when i see it the best part
though about charging the rivian uh is
when you plug it in and it starts
charging
the led bar light at the front
lights up green and starts pulsing it
kind of looks a little weird on camera
but it's it's great i thought i saw
somewhere that it was actually going to
act like a progress bar and sort of
light up from left to right as the
charge is completed but it doesn't do
that maybe that would draw too much
attention or maybe they'll add it with a
software update but it does light up
green but then you know what speaking of
software number seven what is the
software situation so this whole car
it's got some screens inside the whole
cars ui is made in-house by rivian there
is no apple carplay there is no android
auto it's just rivien software through
and through
i was optimistic that would be really
great you know it's a california company
i will say functionally it's very good
and i think it's actually laid out
pretty well you have the dock at the
bottom for organizing things similar to
tesla but it's not super responsive and
especially when manipulating the map at
all like the map is super slow and laggy
but thankfully this is something that
can be improved with future iterations
and yes rivian is one of the car
companies that will be pushing
over-the-air software updates to all
their cars which they can download using
the built-in cell connection or wi-fi
and that's nice to see plus it means
they can add features later if they come
up with more cool stuff as of right now
it's pretty clear by how much is
happening on this 16-inch touchscreen
that they are pretty heavily inspired by
tesla i mean i'm sure many former tesla
employees who now work at rivien would
agree
but i mean it's the dock at the bottom
like i mentioned they have a security
camera mode not sentry mode it's called
gearguard
and it's you know a little more advanced
because it can connect to a cable that
comes with the car so if you tie
something down and someone comes by and
tampers with that cable it'll
automatically record and set off the
alarm but it's got that going the air
conditioning the way the vents move
entirely by software that's just like
tesla even the single scroll wheel and
pair of buttons on either side of the
steering wheel is just like tesla and
even the way you adjust the mirrors and
the steering wheel quinn pointed this
out in his video is exactly like we've
been doing with teslas for years so
plenty of inspiration here in the
software department which is not a bad
thing at all but i look forward to it
getting better too
so number eight speaking of tesla
software
there's a rivian driver assist feature
called driver plus
what is it what does driver plus
actually do
so from my experience it's just a pretty
simple set of driver assist features
like i've seen in lots of other cars
it's not like any sort of advanced
autopilot by any means but it uses the
11 cameras and radar and ultrasonic
sensors all around the car to do
adaptive cruise control lane keep assist
cross traffic warnings emergency braking
all the typical safety type stuff
there is a full-on highway assist that
will do all the steering and braking and
acceleration for you on select highways
you literally engage it just like a
tesla you pull down on the drive stock
all the way twice and that turns it on
and it should keep that lane and turn
the wheel for you and everything i was
able to try it a few times and i noticed
like it was very picky about when it
would engage like many roads with turns
on them at all it would just tell me
driver assist was unavailable sometimes
even on major highway straightaways if i
wasn't in the middle of the lane on the
straightaway it wouldn't turn on
but once it does turn on it works and
just keeps you going with traffic it can
take light turns
uh yeah it's fine it doesn't change
lanes for you just so you know you'll
have to disengage it change lanes
yourself and then re-engage it but again
maybe this can also be changed with a
software update
all right number nine how does it
compare to the other options you know
the other electric pickup trucks i think
that's the natural question like all
right the cyber truck is gonna happen
the f-150 lightning is around the corner
maybe the hummer too i guess so if you
look at the cyber truck that's at least
a year away but when that comes out if
we give it the benefit of the doubt and
they actually deliver what they say then
at the same price as the rivian it
should outperform it but it's also a
much bigger truck with a very
very different style it'll be a triple
motor cyber truck at that price it'll do
14 000 pounds of towing while the rivian
will do 11 000 pounds and of course
cyber truck has the tesla supercharger
advantage a longer predicted range and
it has much much better software but
also the yoke and a wildly minimal
interior but the f-150 lightning might
actually be a more likely comparison so
they tow about the same the range is
also pretty close about the same but
again that's going to be a much bigger
truck too physically speaking
and yeah same with the hummer it's just
ridiculously huge i don't know if
anyone's crush shopping with that
personally from the amount of fun i've
had with this thing
i would pick the rivian every time and i
think it's the most promising for a
bunch of reasons
it's the most dailyable because of the
size and the range and the comfort i
love the powered frunk and the gear
tunnel and it's just so much fun to
drive i really have to cross my fingers
for that rivien adventure network fit
and finish also was excellent pretty
much everywhere inside the truck except
for this little plastic latch on the
gear tunnel storage compartment that
probably could have been metal or
something but whatever and it seems like
they're starting deliveries really soon
i believe the first ones are out there
in the wild already
so here's the big one number 10
should you get it
well this isn't a full review i've only
had the thing for like 30 hours but look
if you've got 70 grand burning a hole in
your pocket and you're looking for a
pickup truck to daily
i would keep this one on the shortlist
it's it's really fun now rivien also has
an suv the r1s coming later it's got a
slightly shorter wheelbase but
essentially it's the same type of
adventure vehicle without a truck bed
that should be cool to see
and it's just it's overall super cool to
see real genuine competition starting to
fill out the space you know i think
someone asked on twitter if this is a
tesla killer or something no not
everything that comes out that's
electric has to be a tesla killer the
tesla truck isn't even out yet but
electric trucks as a whole will benefit
from really good ones coming out so they
all boost each other up
and i love that so the entire industry
going electric just got a little bit
faster thanks to this one thanks to
rivian for letting me borrow this thing
for a day i hope you guys enjoy this
first look thanks for watching and i'll
catch you guys the next one
peace